en fait tu as été génial
avec toi moi aussi je t'ai trouvé très
bien merci inclure les personnes en
situation de handicap par le travail
c'est l'objectif du duo day cette
cinquième édition nationale permettait
aux participants de découvrir un métier
et le monde de l'entreprise en formant
un duo pour une journée avec un salarié
volontaire ce jeudi 17 novembre
s'apprend aerosystème plaisir spécialisé
dans l'équipement et la sécurité des
avions accueillait si binôme sur ce site
de 1300 salariés
et justement c'est aussi l'occasion de
peut-être de faire naître des vocations
auprès de ces de ces salariés personnes
en situation de handicap et de réussir à
créer une suite potentiellement si on
arrive à les reprendre en stage derrière
ou autre ce collaborateur de
l'entreprise accompagnent les salariés
dans leur développement professionnel
avec son binôme il participait pour la
première fois à l'expérience ils ont pu
échanger et assister ensemble à
plusieurs réunions c'est très très
enrichissant parce que la preuve en est
encore c'est que on a des vrais
conversations et moi je fais partie de
ces gens qui n'est pas qui ne sont pas
confrontés au quotidien aux handicap
donc quelque part ça reste pour moi un
gros mot et là on se rend bien compte
que
c'est peut-être pas si gros mots
Jean-Louis a vraiment su me mettre à
l'aise m'a très bien expliqué les choses
j'ai pu vraiment voir le fonctionnement
de l'intérieur
avec bienveillance l'établissement et
service d'aide par le travail de plaisir
spécialisé dans le handicap psychique a
permis l'insertion de ces personnes dans
l'entreprise c'est très important pour
eux parce que ça leur permet à la fois
de se connecter un petit peu à ce à ce
monde qui est différent de celui du
milieu protégé ça permet également de
revoir un petit peu les codes sociaux
professionnels de voir un petit peu
quelles sont les attentes et les
objectifs qu'on a en fait dans une
entreprise standard lors de ce duoday
plus de 30 000 offres d'accueil
était proposé par les employeurs en
France